6 37 on your Finally Friday new this
morning well we know Las Vegas is always
under construction we're just talking
about the repaving project for formula
one but one of the many headache
inducing projects is the work on
Charleston in the Medical District
between I-15 and Rancho that's where our
Laura negretti has been trying to get a
pulse on how the businesses in the area
have been Copeland hey Lauren
yeah good morning well work is really
just getting started on Charleston out
here the city expects to be working out
here and through through September 2024.
now as far as what that work entails a
whole lot of stuff including Water and
Sewer improvements street lights and
accessibility items like adding
sidewalks widening sidewalks adding
trees and bike Lanes you know when I
reached out City staff explained the
city partially acquired 36 properties to
widen the sidewalk again between on
Charleston between Charles between MLK
and Rancho however a local flower shop
out here says traffic and taking some
feed away from their parking area is
making it too tough to stay after nearly
40 years
we were thinking about moving to a
different location just the impact of on
the area and the loss of some of the
property is going to be a little bit
harder for people to access
[Applause]
Gardner says traffic has been a
nightmare really affecting their walk-in
traffic come that Mother's Day time they
had well the city explained it gets the
properties appraised and then they pay
those amounts to the owners in order to
utilize the land to quote improve the
street as the city continues to grow so
again get used to this familiar site
because it will be lasting around here
through September of next year live out
here near Charleston and Rancho the
renegrity 8 news now back to you guys